all right this worked cool so Louise at
work at reddit and we didn't know we're
pageviews I just can't share them all
but sorry in advance if I cough I'm
working through a cold from the weekend
but started in data my first kick out of
college was building Excel services so
Google sheets before Google sheets was
out and these Google guys look and then
work that built out the office image
team so data pipelines of office so
every time you saw a crash or all the
quality quality data out of office the
team built out the pipelines to get all
that back to us which had about a
billion users is a pretty high scale
especially when deciding what cabs to
get from people which is a pretty decent
pretty big data at that since did a
little startup down in LA for a while
and then was gonna do something in the
IEEE data space as a as a new startup
and then ended up getting connected with
one of the partners in Teresa and
introduced me to read it it was like
well if you want to build an AI data
startup you could go and grind for three
years and try to get enough data to make
it a data problem or you could just take
credits which at the time I think had
three data engineers no search team a
handful of people when the relevance
team so I took the challenge
I liked the hets not enough to wear them
because my team is actually called a
reddit intelligence group which is an
acronym for a rig my title on slack is
the rig toolpusher which is the
essentially the director of the oil rig
so very much ascribe to that analogy
there and that's me oh and I guess
Google so we're trying out Google a
number of things largely around
analytics we use mostly bigquery which
reddit scale is actually a lot so we're
taking out kind of small chunks of the
stack but huge amounts of data push it
into it all right Robin Lee I work for a
temporary which is advertising
monetization platform in terms of the
data scale we're dealing with is around
200 terabytes to 300 terabytes active
data and the data data edition is about
20 terabytes comprised
so my data journey started with from a
sperm bank back in 2016 I worked there
for about six years I did everything you
can imagine with amazement Bank starting
from building up trading tools you know
building risk modules and then end up
with sitting on treating desk for two
years on new in their New York office
then I get a little bit bored because of
the economics crash in 2008 we literally
don't have any Commission's or bonus for
two years so and decided to move on and
I'm not computer major so I feel like my
passion is still within the technology
world so I made move from east coast to
the west coast and I started to lead a
team of their engineers as well as data
science engineers so what we do right
now is we are not just moving data
around we're also responsible for the
entire data stack Data Platform starting
from the data infrastructure building up
the servers moving data around to they
were to the data warehousing using the
data making sense of the data as well as
training modules and serve our product
decision based on top of it right so
that's pretty much about me a Google
stack so we starting to use Google from
2015 part of the reason is we were
running a very beefy vertical cluster
I'm not sure if you guys heard of
Vertica that was a commercial licensed
enterprise scale MPP system I would call
it and our cost who was around meeting
daughters to a few million dollars a
year by the perpetual license how were
cost as well as the support cost so we
were thinking to move on to some cheaper
solutions we were looking at let's say
lbs were shaved snowflakes as well as
Google bigquery I'm not sure if you
remember but two of us actually interact
a lot on Stack Overflow regarding the
early questions we have on Google
bigquery so that's that's actually how
to get us started with bigquery backing
than 15 and then in 2017 just this year
we move our entire Hadoop and spark
stack from our coal on Primus Estate
Center into Google out we just 5 18
October so it's pretty impressive
alright that's me thank you I
Andres again so what first got me
interested in data I think was at my
previous company we had a lot of rich
access to user data and it felt like we
were really heavily under utilizing that
and it just kind of was a niche that
when you have all this data you should
be able to get a lot of valuable inside
out of it and then so coming to
thumbtack where we did have a data
platform team started to really
appreciate when you have the proper tool
in infrastructure to really make use of
your data you can use that to drive
really informed decisions and gain some
insights about how your product is being
used in ways that you couldn't have
otherwise as far as using GCP we use it
pretty heavily now our data platform is
almost entirely on Google cloud we have
we use data proc and bigquery we also
use pub/sub that's driving that map
right there along with spark streaming
on data proc yeah so talking about the
your data platform can we can you do a
parallel between like before and after
and and what do you think that change
for the better has you evolved your
platform over time before and after
before GCP before and after GCP or like
earlier stages of GCP as you ramped up
in using different services
so before GCP we had a Hadoop cluster
that we were managing ourselves in AWS
and that worked very well for a year and
a half two years we started hitting some
real growing pains when I came to scale
and a lot of the static provisioning of
every time we needed more capacity we'd
have to manually Persian a new cluster
bring it up do HDFS rebalance wait a
couple days then it could be start being
utilized
we had very spiky utilization of our
resources so all the ad hoc analysis
at how queries were being run were being
run on hive and Impala those would be
conflicting because it was sharing
resources with the yarn and the spark
jobs were running so just this really
inflexible infrastructure made it so
that we wanted something that could grow
more dynamically as our data would grow
and GCP had some very nice offerings in
terms of having data prop clusters that
can be ephemeral and be spun up in 90
seconds run your job and spin back down
bigquery where we can just kind of pass
the buck on to Google and let them deal
with all the operations overhead because
being on-call at this time was a huge
pain it would be basically most of your
week on call would be just putting out
fires so it was a huge win for us
cool how about MJ oh yeah what's your
like the yeah I think I think some of
these a lot of people bring up a very
good point which is you know data engine
is not only about moving that around
it's also about what tools to choose and
what - or tools to utilize right and
think up to that point we previously had
a very large on-premises data center we
built ourselves we basically bought up a
couple million dollars worth of hardware
strapping together also as a company to
do almost more offline small hand works
and throw it into the u.s. East
datacenter right next to areas
internally through with a direct connect
fiber link all of the work is pretty
cool but it has a lot of operational
overheads right and we have our 300 to
400 machine hadoop production cluster
typically sit on bare metal hardware if
any nose goes offline we have to deal
with them right so and then after we
started looking at bigquery after we
move our in time PP solution in the
bigquery we realized a company size of
type Dre which is around 200 to 300
people it's pretty impressive to do
on-premises data centers one thing but
on the other thing is we need to think
about optional overhead as well as you
know the actual running cost for your
infrastructure so that's why we're
looking starting
looking at moving our entire structure
to a cloud-based and we did a lot of
benchmarking in comparison my Google
account reps helps me a lot with that
and the end of the day it works really
well so we merge our entire hadoop
infrastructure from on-premise data
center into Google cloud but a little
bit different from this gentleness usage
we didn't use data proc we basically
built our own
elastic Hadoop and spark cluster and to
run on Google Cloud utilizing the cloud
power for very spiky workload that's
before and after cool so we were on hive
before I've always been a fan of not
building my own infra when I don't need
to like data infrastructure is not going
to be the differentiator for reddit it's
gonna be what makes us exceed or not so
we were just in Qubo which is kind of
cool but the difference between Q Bowl
and bigquery is essentially like picture
driving a manual car in the 60s when you
had to do a lot of work in maintenance
and checking the engine oil and doing
all that stuff versus like an automatic
car this day and age where you don't
have to take it in for a checkup and
like 50,000 miles so it's even less
overhead on the engineering side and it
helped with some of the the speed
concerns that we had that said you have
to actually structure your data
cognoscenti of someone especially when
you have the amount of data that reddit
has off some of the limitations because
even bigquery has limits everyone has
limits yeah sorry so there is some
thinking that you have to do around that
and there are some differences with the
abilities that you have in hive or so we
have in bigquery to to acknowledge but
it's certainly a lot less maintenance
overhead than we had even in Cuba which
is a lot of theoretically is much easier
than running your own which is much
easier than one of your own hive
clusters but was still basically the the
speed of iteration was the main reason
to try it out like being able to write a
query run it and get it back really
quickly versus waiting two minutes for
cueball high flyers to spin up or having
preso clusters that were big enough and
that your sequel query was like
optimized enough to actually be able to
run against
so bigquery just got some of those
concerns away from us and there were
more tools that out of the box were
built to support it so things like mold
analytics looker periscope data what you
can just point to you know bigquery in
the cloud versus having to figure out
how you get your you know clusters that
cue ball spin up somewhere to feed up to
some of these daily analytics tools so
some what do you use bigquery I mean for
Philippe I mean if you can give an
example where if seem like a very
interesting transformation for a
customer going from something more
cumbersome maybe to a much more
streamlined solution so let me bring the
before-and-after to the every person is
a data scientist especially people here
and how these tools enable laziness like
if I have a question if I want to find
out something about ready or Stack
Overflow or hacker news or any other
site that looks interesting if I have to
start by scraping and I just need to
have a lot of energy to finish that
project first that's before now I just
need to know that I'm available
somewhere it's rarely on the query I can
just connect and start asking questions
right away and I think that's how ready
got a warning that we query existed
basically there's this guy Jason
Bumgarner in Washington that started
scraping every reddit comment finally he
started sharing that data that date
ended up in bigquery and then when they
this reddit itself sees that that date
is there and starts writing some queries
without any other effort other than the
data is read in there for you and so
it's useful it's insightful it's I
didn't have to analyze anything I didn't
have to prepare anything to be able to
analyze it
huh so let's talk a little bit about
work clothes the type of work clothes
that this technology powers is critical
to get some examples on where does the
end value come from and kind of like in
terms of the data that flows through the
system what's that data what does it
represent for you and for for Felipe is
more around like interesting examples
like you you showed an examples with
taxes what else have you seen that's
more like transformative in nature let
me give the microphone to the actual
user first so right now we're using a
primary for analytics so how many page
views we get who's looking at what what
like what kind of aggregate information
we have how feature users are running
I'm actually working on getting
availability numbers into there so
getting a cheap proxy logs parsed and
into bigquery so we can see by service
what the availability is a lot of
business metrics ok ours that we tracked
I'm on site
you know DEA use all that kind of stuff
some of the more and then there's some
interesting like investigations if you
look at things like anti evil after is
around like spam avoidance botnet
detection vote manipulation there's a
lot of information there that we may not
that the difference in that kind of
workflow is that it's very ad hoc so you
don't really have like if you had a way
that you could automatically detect bots
or vote manipulation there was 100%
accurate you would just productize it
and then block them which we do but it's
an arms race so then they change things
so you did a much more ad hoc flow or we
start seeing some weird behavior on the
site and you just have to dig into the
data and pivot in a number of ways and
try to figure out okay what are the
common themes or the common threads like
is it actually a botnet is it a sleeper
so like are there different things that
people are doing here and that really
helps to kind of that ad hoc one of the
milk type queries so it's been super
helpful there where you know if each one
of the iterations on hive will take a
couple minutes where you know if you're
doing it just a small time range it
takes a couple seconds to get an answer
for looking at enough data where you
need like things where you need
aggregates right like to know if I have
a vote manipulation or button that I
can't look at like 100 votes I have to
look at millions of votes and so
seen like what the patterns are so
that's been super helpful there
so essentially right now like business
metrics KPIs
understanding how people are using the
site how the site's behaving and then as
well as ad hoc investigations on you
know different things around the the
anti evil space there's a couple of
interesting things we've built and I
have one query that actually gives me a
listing like a same thing as you see
when you go to the front page you had
reddit
so it's sourced by your hot algorithm
now or some models that we're starting
to experiment with but with any
analytics event that I have I have a
query that I can just point to that
event and create generate a front page
based on that query so I could see like
what would the front picture what it
look like if all we use was shares to
rank content or views from different
countries or you know size of the number
of comments those kind of things so cool
for us pretty much the same right you
know and we mentioned we use it for a
hawk analysis a lot of hoc queries as
well as supporting reporting that drive
insights we also use Vickery for
lightweight ETLs such as we do a lot of
modeling in in our sparkle hadoop
cluster but we use bigquery to extract a
lot of features to a lot of the data
cleanups and eventually fade into the
Hadoop and spark causative were motor
trainings I think there is one more
thing which is pretty interesting in
bakeries is it leaves very well with the
other Google products such as stack
drivers which please the longings as
well as all the API is that Google
supports one of the good very
interesting example which is you know
good good Baker is pricing at per query
level at how much data you moved your
query
so it's eliminate a lot of DBM in work
and infrastructure operational work but
a new type of work which is introduced
like bigquery and slightly I'm sorry but
it is how do you curb your cost right so
how do you keep your cost at minimum
level making sure your users are running
meaningful curries to get the results so
we calling all the Google API is to get
all the curries usage per user per query
level normalizes them you know stripe
out a dates part the common filter parts
and putting it into bigquery table for
analyzing Vickery costs which is I'll
show actually yeah
Kyle like a feedback loop stuff like
that one dashboard yeah yeah if you
don't care if you're not be careful your
cost for one particular battery could go
out pretty fast please turn on your cost
controls yeah out there but it's also
like it's well the one thing I wanted
out here is being in a place where you
have this knob is fairly empowering
right being able to decide that I want
to spend more when I need to spend more
sorry Big KRIT definitely produce all
the knobs and controls for curvature for
cost controls and access control so I'm
just giving the example here and we
definitely saw some unexpectedly high
bigquery cost at first and realized it's
because we're putting these powerful
tools in people's hands and they want to
use them and do new things with them
so also educating users like maybe you
don't need to do select stars or maybe
you should use this partition time
column and that helps a lot yeah I think
we are we use bigquery in similar ways
it's really enabled some new avenues to
do really fast analytics and on large
datasets that we didn't have the
capability of before I'd say one of our
biggest one of the things that I enjoyed
the most of it about gzp is using data
proc because we used a hose so heavily
having any developer able to spin up an
arbitrarily sized cluster to test their
job to not have to wait for this big
spark batch job to run has been really
powerful and really enabled faster
iteration so as a developer that's
become a huge boon for us awesome team a
innovative uses what it really made me
mean I'm pretty proud of
being particle cloud is as you listen
all of these examples and how they are
solving problems at their huge scale
that everyone here has access to the
same tools you can basically run the
same processes you can prepare yourself
work at the same scale limiting cost is
an issue but it's not a hard issue to
solve you just put the cost controls
there but just having access to the same
size of the same tools can really want
serve you for fun but then if you want
to work at any of these places or many
more you're ready you have everything
you've tried everything and you are
speaking the same language from day zero
our cost is only an issue because we
like that's the the $10,000 dashboard
was a mold analytics dashboard which was
set to refresh every five minutes that
were scanning every single screen view
of Reddit like that's just dumb only so
it's not really and then it's the amount
of data is ridiculous like most if
you're playing with it like you might
spent a few bucks if you're using it on
your own projects or on most things
these are this is doctor when you're
when you took anyone talk about like a
top for a company or a top for a website
in the US then you're gonna have those
kind of things but at that level 10,000
bucks a section are level money so okay
cool so we talked a lot about like past
present let's talk about the future so
assuming you have this like magic one
what are the areas in which you are
investing moving forward then what do
you think is going to make like material
difference from you for you so excited
about the ml stuff on Google cloud so
there's a when you talk about same
people having the same tools and being
able to work across companies there's
actually one of the pieces that was kind
of surprising and as a positive was a
lot of the m/l community is actually
using go cloud on their own projects
because it's a little bit more
developer-friendly is a little bit
easier than AWS AWS is probably the
least developer for any thing out there
so that was really helpful because we
can go and recruit and the folks are
recruiting actually get excited that
were open to exploring that in the
future so having our data that's one
step cleaning it up is another one and
Google certainly has a leg up and a lot
of the
ml api's and functionality that we might
want to start playing with and using in
the future so that's an area I'm excited
about I think another one is just
continuous improvements on on bigquery
there's there's definitely still
low-hanging fruit even though it's a big
area where we could significant increase
like speed of queries cost reduction and
ability like you know even the the
JavaScript UDF stuff is a pretty
powerful that you can do there so we're
just I'm we know we're just scratching
the surface we're just we're dumping
data there and then running queries on
it there's a lot on the whole Google
cloud ecosystem that I think we really
introduced are playing with a very
similar observation on my site we we
have MPP system in bigquery we have our
tail lake on GC s and we have our entire
tip on GCE so now what great so we have
all the data we have all the pipeline's
move over the next step for us is to
translate our simple machine learning
modules such as linear agressions
random forests over to deep learning
more juice so we've been starting to
look at tensor solutions offered by
cloud among our POC deep learning module
produce very impressive results are I
think the biggest challenge for us is
not to trow the trainer module on Google
cloud is how to survey at real time back
to our customers that's a problem
challenge for ourselves so but having
that in mind I mean the next step for us
is definitely how do you know gradually
moving from a spark driven the machine
learning path over to deep learning
driving path our site that's pretty much
all my site I think I'm the same boat
it's the the two of you one additional
thing that I'm excited about is the
unification of batch and streaming
paradigms I think kind of making the
leap to straight a streaming world is
pretty daunting and it takes a lot of
upfront thought about how to make that
switch and with the rise of the Apache
beam and
spark structured streaming that's
becoming a lot easier and I'm excited to
see that awesome so it's give me two bit
yes Mathilde learning is completely the
future and what everyone is really
focused right now everyone wants to
learn tensor flow etc etc so that's
pretty excited to see how things are
going to get easier to use but then at
the same time I personally have not move
into the material learning real I just
think there's so much more to do with
data like anything mature learning will
require that engineers that's the name
of the the meet up how do we move data
and especially excited about real-time
data so we have possible now available I
would really love to see more public
feeds of fresh live stream data people
doing things with it
building pipelines over it totally
mathilde learning that okay so I will
and questions go around but then I want
you to think about your questions as we
as we close close down this session so
my my kind of my final question for you
is if you were to if you are able to go
back based on what you know today and
tell story to yourself
tell tell a bunch of advices like what
will that be think a little bit better
how to spread apart your datasets we we
put everything over analytics of event
and one dataset with bigquery you don't
get the ability to do custom partitions
like you do in hive or hierarchical
partition so everything's partition by
day and turns out that we just generate
too much data per day to even even at
bigquery scales to be able to scan
through one day's worth of data in a
reasonable time so leveraging the
ability different datasets as basically
one level of partitioning your data
would have been a way to be much faster
we kind of we were avoiding we were way
too much into the denormalized camp and
avoiding joins from due to the
slowness of our hive solutions there and
I it's I have not had any issues with
joins and paid queries so I would be
more open to doing joint and separating
my data it's a refreshing thing to hear
about like big data joins big data
insurance used to be in combat well I
think for me if I want to read it over I
probably want to have data visualization
a lot more research data visualizations
to tell my story of how we're dealing
with data how we using data to drive
insights and giving driving the revenue
of the company I think that's very
important because a lot of your data
engineers do a lot of 30 works and grant
works but you know in order for your
company to be a data driven company in
East you definitely need a lot of
insights and a lot of visualization of
you data not just a data sitting on a
spreadsheet I think along the same vein
as visualization we had a bug a little
while back where some of our front end
servers some front end servers were
stopped sending event data to the back
end and no one noticed for a while for
an embarrassingly long time so having
realizing that not all failures are
catastrophic and that they could be
partial or subtle and having more rich
monitoring and alerting to make sure
that your data is trustworthy and safe
is something that is kind of obvious in
hindsight sweet so any questions from
from the audience I think we all have
hi so my question was sorta on the data
governance side and you mentioned in
terms of understanding which
visualizations or business questions you
needed answered what are some either
like process level mechanisms or actual
tools like you guys have like a glossary
of like certain reports that you guys
certify or like what are some of the
ways you kind of manage you know we are
getting accurate data and should be used
for x y&z question result data governess
and I'm swimming leading into like the
QA side of it things that broke break
but about a little bit more - there's
all-around PII protection of data do you
probably don't like well analytics is
great you probably don't want everyone
in the company to have access the gun
writer for example not everyone a
company should know every single post at
a particular account can see right like
that's kind of creepy
there is IP information PII information
our privacy policy I think it's like 90
days
excuse me or we can keep PII on people
so things like an IP address we keep for
awhile but then we have to go and mask
it so what happens when the scripts to
mask it or the items to mask it actually
break and you're no longer I'm asking
that so we've done a lot of data
governess on Reddit at least is first
you gotta have a breakdown of what data
you're collecting where you're putting
it and where it lives some of the
conversation we were just having is some
people scrape those input data in
different places
so there's also some ideas over like
okay at some point we need to start
caring about where the data lives
outside of that to make sure they said
we're protecting your users protecting
their information but firstly the first
first step is inaud it like take takes
not at of where you are there's
companies actually the same way that you
get third-party security artists there's
third-party data audits so if you're at
that level of data governance you can
get a third party to come in look at
your data see what you're storing where
you have it like where data leakage is
and it's actually not that hard to
accidentally leak data to you're at
least you've within your company like
there's so many process there's things
that go to an event collector that I
coughed up I apply and then we dump it
to s3 or GCS and then bigquery in any of
those if all the sudden other people
have access to it for other purposes now
they can you know pipe in and look at
data they shouldn't be looking at then
there's the whole quality side we've had
the same bugs where Android rented app
stop sending events I don't think it was
screen views but one of our core events
just stopped sending and we didn't
notice until like a couple weeks after
the build was out because Android like
the adoption curve was a little bit
smaller but we didn't have a simple
thing like a dashboard of bill to build
or the play to deploy what are your key
events and which ones have significant
changes over those so things like that
is another way to have governance but
first step on it then the second one is
like if you don't have it automated if
you don't have monitoring over it so you
have to have a set of like what are my
golden events what are the ones that
can't break and there should be a test
for every single one of those if there's
ever a deploy and your Delta of those
goes above a certain amount you got a
fire and alert if it's not automated if
you're relying on people to notice it
you're not gonna catch it you're gonna
miss those bugs any other questions I
have another one around the organization
what there anything else so it's kind of
related to governance there are various
ways in which you can organize data
between projects and folders and I'm
wondering like how do you organize your
data do you split storage versus query
or not or what are like some of the
things you do badly to go back to my
what I would tell myself so we did two
things we had we version our event so
first thing when we started about it
there was schema-less events which is
horrible you always want a schema I
always want to enforce it you know be
able to know what fields are expected
what's not expected so we had the v1
events and for those we actually broke
him out by data set and we had one
project for all the events different
projects I shouldn't say I don't know if
it surprised what is the so data sets
are grouped by the projects a big worry
okay so projects I guess is the the
thing you're not thinking of maybe I'm
thinking obtains project is a Google
Cloud project right okay sorry so
ignoring what I was saying
we have won multiple tables is what I
wanted to have not multiple data sets I
have one data set in one table for all
my v2 events and then I can actually
segment them any more granular than
today's or the data so we organized but
we have one project for all of our
production events we have one project
for employee data sets so things that
are like ad hoc analytics and those are
literally organized by the employee name
so we know exactly who to go to and see
like if they're just trying out
different things or trying out different
data sets and they're not polluting the
the official project and then we have
now the idea of like these reporting
tables and in aggregate tables which
were eventually forming into our golden
data sets so what are the blessed tables
and reports that we that we have cleaned
up data on that we've got them pre
aggregated so that we can do queries
really fast on the business side so we
definitely started down this path on
Google Cloud Storage where we were
trying to not have too many buckets and
realize that was the wrong decision that
it's better to have more buckets because
they are a pretty singular unit of
control over whether it's lifecycle
management or permissions or the storage
class buckets are tend to be the way
that GCS as you control them so we've
started moving more towards more buckets
with fewer folders within them as far as
bigquery goes we do have particular
blessed datasets where they have what we
consider analytics data which is kind of
the nicely sanitized cleaned pre joined
data which anyone who has kind of more
cursory or casual questions about key
metrics of the company can query those
tables and trust that the analytics
teams have done their job to make sure
it's same data and clean in there I
guess another benefit when you have
multiple projects or buckets which is
cost control array so you know you can
structure your projects into different
tiers and different tiers can have
different capability run queries so you
can set up caps on different bucket as
well so that's another way of doing the
cost control in bigquery
I have two questions action item related
one is what should I tell my product
managers what change would you like from
Google Cloud excellent and the other
question if you had to be someone here
once a weekend project what would you
recommend them to the like what would be
a fun project for the audience custom
partitions hierarchical partitions in
the query like that would save my life
and we can projects I would say if
you're looking for extra projects reddit
is hiring so you should just talk to me
and I'll pay you to do your weekend
projects if you don't want to get paid
for the work I literally think I'm gonna
know that it's more the date engineering
but I think anything like ml is is huge
it's gonna be even bigger and if you
want to be a data engineer in the future
likelihood it's gonna be a data engineer
for ml projects so I would pick whatever
thing you are manually doing today some
repetitive process some like
classification thing and go play and
figure out if you can actually quite
create some stupid dumb models to be
able to predict something for you to
reread there is one really really nice
feature about the query I really like
which is your hyper log plus plus I'm
not sure if in guys all know what hyper
lock lock does it's basically a
algorithm that Divali developed in 1980s
or in 1989
sort of seven years younger than my age
but all right so but basically what it
does is trying to at doing estimation of
our distinct values over your data sets
and Google take it up to another level
which is the you publish a white paper
about hyper lock lock plus plus which
you know typically if you see our
general algorithm a gave you the
accuracy about 0.5 percent which means
if you actually count distinct values
and also using the hyper local
algorithm to count the distinct values
that the difference should be around
zero five zero point five percent but in
Google's case is about 0.05 percent it's
really impressive how occur is and also
Google has a really nice feature which
you can starting to partition your
distinct values into a synopsis or
sketches which means let's say if I
previously even want to count last seven
days of distinct users we need to do is
you always need to get all the users for
the last seven days and starting to
count these things of them right but now
if you in Google be crew you can do is
for each day you can count the distinct
values and prove and put them into a
hash string a story for that day do it
for the next six days and when you want
to look back for the last seven days of
distinct you just need to merge all of
the last seven days together which saves
you a lot of computational power so
that's one of the nicest features I
really like in could be querying is it
other npp has the same feature but
Google in terms of the speed and
accuracy is the most at the best I've
ever seen yeah not so much features but
since you're offering some pm's ears
being a little bit more public about
when there are new changes or releases
to bigquery it would be nice we've had
breaking changes where there was in
cabal incompatibilities between data
proc and bigquery and we would file
support tickets and not hear back about
them so that was a little discouraging
and also have noticed particular service
outages of up to 20 30 minutes they
never show up on the Status dashboard
which is a little frustrating when
you're on Pedro duty and it's there's an
outage that you're observing and there's
no word
wait they didn't have requests I'm gonna
throw in two more native sampling would
be awesome
we literally have an ETL that automatic
creates datasets that are simple just so
we can query them they just simply would
be amazing and now this is coming from
reddit so you have to feel this one like
make sure you why not look ugly
and knowing that read it looks really
ugly like this bet can I add a few
things no it's I mean when we move to
bakery I think the reliability is
actually one of the reason we move over
to bakery
we had we run close to in metal place in
our own datacenter on AWS on vertical in
recive to the reliability we sing on
those clusters and nowhere compares to
bakery so I think the reliability in
Google Cloud is actually very very good
the only thing that confused me is the
name of different products Google have
like data property the pipe data live
data data studio it actually confuse me
sometimes which two to use and what
tools is for what cool so we'll will
stop here thanks thanks to everyone for
sharing your experience sharing your
thoughts about how things can improve
them what enjoy working for thank you
for for attending the event so we have
half an hour left in which we can just
socialize have a drink continue the
conversations and that's it
who gets the hair so we have one
question one great question he gets the
hair thank you very much and hope to see
you at the next one thank you